[A] So for the folks that are a little bit more
[A] green to the industry.
[A] How does that benefit them, all of what Aptos is building?
[B] The only blockchain use case
[B] that really found real-world use is financial applications.
[B] For retail users.
[B] This is another option for them
[B] to get into the capital markets.
[B] Traditional way, it was real estate.
[B] Stock trading.
[B] Futures trading, options.
[B] Right?
[B] All these good stuff.
[B] They are great.
[B] But the legacy market that we are using today
[B] is actually not fair to the retail audience
[B] because the edge that you have on the trade
[B] comes not from information.
[B] It actually comes from how close you are to the data center.
[B] So that's an unfair playing field for people.